Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Wie wie ich hörte bist du zu Tränen gerührt.
Ja, so kann man das nennen.
Herzlich willkommen zu Logbuch Netzpolitik, die achtundsechzigste Ausgabe steht an und äh wir waren etwas unstit in der letzten Zeit und das hatte Gründe,
wir müssen mal uns mal vorstellen. Und Linus Neumann und Gast haben wir auch, den verraten wir gleich. Ähm nämlich,
Bruder, eigentlich Bruder, oder? Man sagt Bruder,
Wo ist der Bruder? Genau. Und mit dir wollen wir heute noch ein bisschen äh schwatzen über ähm C3 S und Gamer, das stellen wir aber mal nach hinten an und gehen hier also erstmal gegen die äh auf die Kurz,
Mitteilungen. Was sonst noch so ist. Wobei wir gleich äh einschließend äh äh einschränken müssen,
So richtig intensiv haben wir die Nachrichten diesmal nicht zusammenkämmen können. Und das hat auch damit zu tun, dass Linus äh auf Urlaub war,
Ja, dachte sich so, Wetter in Deutschland könnte auch besser sein. Ja, also auch so die Luft ist eigentlich hat einfach nicht den richtigen Gasgehalt,
Und überhaupt wart ihr mal ein bisschen nach Revolution.
Ja, ich war in äh Istanbul übers Wochenende ähm und habe mir da ähm habe mich da an den an den Demonstrationen und den Protesten gegen Erdogan beteiligt.
Wie sie alle sagen.
Tritt zurück.
Ah, warum nennen Sie ihn eigentlich alle beim zweiten Vornamen? Ist das irgendwie eine besondere Beleidigung?
Das ist einfach verächtlich,
Beim zweiten Vornamen zu nennen. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Vielleicht liegt's auch einfach daran, dass die äh dass sie ähm den, dass man den ersten nicht so gut skandieren kann oder so, aber ähm,
Ich habe gelesen, es ist eher so eine ähm so eine verächtliche, eine Art der Verachtung ist. Und ähm,
man so mit den Leuten spricht, sagen sie sowieso immer nur er. Also sie nennen ihn nicht beim Namen, so. Auch, also es scheint auch eine äh,
eine Verachtung zu sein, wenn sie sagen, wenn sie irgendwie sagen, dann meinen sie immer äh ihn.
Der Unaussprechliche.
Der dessen Name man gar nicht erst nennt.
Es ist eine sehr äh sehr krasse Protestbewegung, die sich da formiert hat, einfach sehr, sehr,
sehr viele Menschen. Dieser Podest kommt eher aus dem, aus dem oder kommt sehr klar aus dem äh eher Gebildeten und freiheitlichen Lager, die sich hauptsächlich eben gegen den Mangel an Demokratie und ähm,
und Republik da äh richten,
also die diese Machtkonzentration auf äh Erdogan da kritisieren und ähm die Türkei äh wieder in in der oder mehr in der Blüte der Demokratie sehen wollen, als sie es jetzt ist,
sind so Situationen, ähm die es da gibt, also beispielsweise wurden jede Nacht, wurde einfach mal die komplette Innenstadt vollgesprüht mit ähm,
mit ähm mit mit Parolen. Die waren dann am nächsten Morgen wieder weg,
Wir haben uns immer, wir haben uns halt gefragt, wie das, wie das passiert, ob die, ob die Regierungstruppen irgendwie alles überstreichen. Das sind aber hauptsächlich tatsächlich die die Geschäfts,
Inhaber, die sich, also die so eine Angst haben, dass sie schräg angeguckt werden, wenn sie diese Parolen nicht wegmachen.
Hm, bevor.
Also so ein Vorauseilender Gehorsam. Es gibt irgendwie ähm,
also auch auch die Inhaber von kleineren Geschäften äh fürchten sich, wenn sie äh Demonstranten irgendwie schützen oder so, ja also wenn die wenn die in ihre äh Geschäfte fliehen vor vor Tränengas oder so, weil sie dann halt eine Form von Rache äh fürchten vom
vom Regime Erdogan. Ähm Opfer von Polizeigewalt haben äh niemanden, an den sie sich wenden können, denn du bist einfach nicht,
Staatsanwalt, wenn du nicht Erdogans treuer treuer Freund bist,
und äh,
Das hat da hat er wirklich ein sehr äh sehr krasses Ausmaß. Gleichzeitig waren das so ungefähr die friedlichsten Proteste, die ich je gesehen habe. War völlig ähm.
Also ich das war wirklich völlig irrsinnig, wie die Leute immer wieder also wirklich einfach nur Parolen skandieren,
losgelaufen sind und denen war ganz klar, gleich fliegen hier die Gasgranaten und die flogen auch.
Und dann sind sie weg, sind sie halt zurückgezogen, relativ ruhig, geordnet, halt so, dass man nicht in den vollen Nebel kommt, ähm haben sich gesammelt irgendwie sich mit ähm,
Mit so äh Maloxan behandelt. Das ist so ein Neutralisator, der der diese Schmerzen dann sehr schnell sehr stark lindert,
und haben sich gesammelt, haben dann wieder langsam angefangen zu klatschen, sich Mut zugesprochen, sind wieder losgegangen und dann haben sie wieder Gas in die Fresse bekommen als gegenüber Stunden so.
Und da hat nicht einer äh äh irgendwie mal gesagt, so jetzt wird's mal Zeit, dass wir uns hier auch mal wehren oder so. Das Einzige, was die Leute gemacht haben, das sind die, vor denen hatte ich den meisten Respekt, die hatten Gasmasken und so ein ein ähm,
und einen Handschuh an, so ein so ein Bauarbeiterhandschuh und haben diese Gasgranaten aufgehoben und zurückgeworfen. Kommt's natürlich nicht weit, du kannst ihn nicht weit werfen, aber du hilfst natürlich einer Menge Menschen, wenn du die wieder weiter weg wirst, ne, dass die nicht in den, in den vollen Nebel kommen,
Also das äh ja sowieso, die hatten alle äh bunte Bauhema.
Was war daran jetzt so gefährlich? Also.
Ey, weißt du, ne, also dieses Gas, ja, wenn wenn das, wenn du dem zu nahe kommst, dann kann ich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, ist,
enorm fürchterlich. Ja, das also Tränengas ist da wirklich ein ein absolut harmloser Begriff, dass das reißt dir das ganze Gesicht brennt. Du kannst auch nicht mehr atmen.
Also es ist gar nicht mal nur die Atmung und die Augen, sondern es ist.
Nein, also alles.
Hautkontakt, man will da gar nicht in der Nähe sein.
Kannst es nicht aushalten,
Also es ist einfach äh also der die das das an der das brennt an der Haut, das brennt fürchterlich in den Augen. Das brennt in der Nase, es brennt in der Lunge. Das ist äh du, dessen Gefühl als würdest du sterben.
Es ist wirklich nicht zu ertragen. Es sei denn, du hast jetzt eine, ja, eine Gasmaske auf und ähm was, was also auf der Straße wurden überall.
Ah du bräuchtest dann wirklich auch so eine Gasmaske, die über den ganzen Kopf geht sozusagen, aber auch die Armer würden auch weh tun jetzt. Also man muss eigentlich komplett bekleidet sein. Eigentlich bräuchte man halt Schutz.
Also wirklich
so ein so ein Ding aufzuheben ist äh ist noch mal echt eine Mutprobe, die ich äh vor der ich großen Respekt habe. Das grundsätzlich abzubekommen. Ich meine, das geht ja vorbei. Die haben die haben alle dieses, also
man nimmt da so ein Magenmittel. Das sind neutralisator für, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Sodbrennen hast. Und äh den mischt du einfach mit Wasser und die haben alle
alle so kleine Spritzpistolen und wenn du dann quasi da rausrennst, dann kommen dir schon die Leute entgegen und spritzen dir dieses Zeug ins Gesicht und in die Augen, woraufhin das dann halt eine Minute später äh sind die sind die Schmerzen weg. In die Lunge kannst du dir das aber natürlich nicht machen.
Ja, also hilft auch nur begrenzt.
Ähm ja, hilfbegrenzt, aber ist schon mal gut, wenn du wieder was sehen kannst, weil dass du was sehen kannst, ist so die Grundvoraussetzung dafür, dass du weiter wegrennen kannst,
in dem in den Wasserwerfern ähm hat man ja häufig gesehen, ist äh ein rotes Zeug drin, das ist, glaube ich, maze oder so, also auch ein Reizstoff. Das heißt, wenn du wenn der Wasserwerfer sprüht, hast du auch schon äh,
gleiche Problem, das ist ein etwas anderer Schmerz, der brennt aber dafür noch viel stärker auf der Haut. Also ähm,
Da wird wirklich äh wirklich mit krasser Gewalt gegen die Menschen vorgegangen, die da nichts anderes machen, als,
als ich zu versammeln. Ja, also dieser Park, der da äh,
geräumt wurde, da gibt's ja genug Fotos von das war einfach ein friedliches Camp, ne. Da haben die Leute irgendwie, was weiß ich, Bibliotheken und umsonst Leben gemacht und Magazine, wo sie irgendwie,
miteinander teilen und so. Das ist,
Ist schon wirklich, wirklich irre und ich bin sehr, sehr, sehr verwundert über den über die Ausdauer, die die Menschen haben, über die Ruhe, mit der die sich da immer wieder eingasen lassen äh und über den wirklich,
winzigen Anteil an Menschen, die da wirklich mit ähm mit Gewalt sich dann wieder zur Wehr setzen.
Durch Zufall, kann ich ja hier den den Podcast hören durch Zufall vor Ort auch John F Nebel und Kalle Kornblum von Metronaut getroffen.
Und äh die haben da haben da direkt aus dem Geschehen gepodcastet. Ähm kann man.
Dann der Metrolaut.
Der Metrolaut Podcast zu äh zu finden unter Metronaut DE. Bis jetzt sind, glaube ich, so fünf Episoden veröffentlicht.
Kommt ist auch noch mehr zu rechnen.
Das weiß ich nicht, rechne mal schon damit, dass sie noch einiges an.
Okay. Ja, ich habe mir das so angehört. Das sind halt so Live-Berichterstattungen direkt aus der Masse und äh oh Gott und jetzt kommen die Gasgranaten und lass mal hier rüber gehen, so oh hoppala, da steht ja noch ein Wasserwerk, weil das mal lieber darin gehe, so, oh, jetzt haben sie uns gerade in die Sackgasse getrieben,
hm alle schreien, äh schon ein bisschen ja.
Man hat aber keinerlei Kampfgeräusche oder so, ne? Bis auf die Kartuschen, die abgeschlossen werden. Klingt's eher wie ein Spaziergang so.
Also die Leute werden da halt auch auf einmal sehr ruhig, wenn dieses Gas kommt, dann wird die wird der Protest relativ leise, weil die.
Stellen sie die Atmung ein.
Mehr atmen können. Ja, ohne atmen keine Parolen, ne?
Aber ich habe, also ich habe auch diese Metrolaut äh äh Episoden gehört und da sind jetzt also sind ja auch dann so Gespräche mit den Leuten vor Ort, vor der Räumung, nach der Räumung so mit drin. Ähm ist auf jeden Fall eine.
Unsere Empfehlung.
Na gut, auf jeden Fall freue ich mich, dass jetzt äh wieder einen ganzen Stücken zusammen zurückgekommen bist und äh wir hier weitermachen kann,
Ja, dann hast du es auch nochmal ein paar äh Kurzmeldungen hier äh einbringen, bevor wir uns unseren Hauptthema zu wenden. Richtig viel scheint ja nicht passiert zu sein
es gab so ein wenig um die unsägliche Drosseldebatte. Man merkt es ist Wahlkampf sogar die FDP ist jetzt mal wieder für Verbesserung,
Das ist Zustand. Äh Herr Rösler ist da zum Beispiel unterwegs und meint, das ging ja alles gar nicht. Man muss ja immer was tun und Netzneutralität, das wäre ja auch mal wichtig,
keine Ahnung, ich habe das nicht weiter zur Kenntnis genommen, was äh hast du da raus.
Ich habe den, also die dieser Verordnungsentwurf ist ihr, also sie wollen eine Verordnung zu Gewährleistung der Netzneutralität irgendwie,
Aus ihrem Wirtschaftsministerium fallen lassen und ähm er sagt also erst mit den bisherigen Zugeständnissen der Telekom nicht zufrieden. Wir erinnern uns. Es gab nicht, das haben wir glaube ich gar nicht berichtet. Es wurde nämlich das Drossel-Limit erhöht. Es soll jetzt nicht,
soll nicht mehr auf dreihundertvierundachtzig äh Kilobit pro Sekunde gedrosselt werden, sondern auf zwei Mbit.
Das Tränengas der öffentlichen Empörung zeigt äh offensichtlich etwas Wirkung so, weil äh das war dann doch wohl ein bisschen zu hardcore. Das konnten sie einfach keinem vermitteln. Und ich finde es sehr interessant, dass dieses Wort Drossel,
dem das aufgekommen ist und das ist ja jetzt schon ein paar Monate her,
die Öffentlichkeit so recht nicht verlassen hat. Also es heißt jetzt immer Drossel kommen,
Also ich meine Marketingtechnisch ist das Ding für die Telekom jetzt schon ein Desaster,
Also dafür, dass wir hier nur von einer Vertragsänderung sprechen für von einer Maßnahme, die in zwei Jahren vielleicht dann greift, ist das Ding äh schon ein ziemlicher Schuss in Ofen geworden,
Das zeigt sich natürlich jetzt auch an so einer Reaktion, weil versuchen sie sozusagen da so ein bisschen das Kind äh wieder aus dem Brunnen zu holen. Aber ich glaube, das.
Also ich ich glaube, das ist ein das ist ein ein strategischer Schritt hier. Also wir reden immer noch von der Drosselung auf irgendwie vier Prozent, ne?
Was du hast, also auf dem Land haben ja manchmal die Leute auch nicht mehr als zwei Megabit, für die.
Die werden sich bemühen schnell, ihre fünfundsiebzig Gig durchzusaugen, damit sie endlich zwei M mitbekommen.
Ja ja. Versucht das mal mit zwei Megabit irgendwie bist du auch eine Weile dabei.
Also aber natürlich äh sind ein VDSL-Anschluss mit mit äh fünfzig Mbit, wer dann immer noch auf äh auf vier Prozent seiner Geschwindigkeit gedrosselt, also das ist jetzt alles andere als ein äh Grund zu feiern, ne? Das äh.
Nö, nee, das kann jetzt im Prinzip eigentlich nur Mut machen, da noch weiter drauf zu halten, weil es zeigt sich eben, dass äh dass eben nicht alles so belanglos ist. Man wäre das keine Maßnahme, wäre das eine Maßnahme, über die sich keiner Sorgen machen müsste, warum dann die Änderung, ja? Also.
Genau, also und vor allem in wenn wir wir reden von zweitausendsechzehn. Wer weiß, was was zwei Mbit äh zu der Zeit dann noch wert sein wollen. Und wie gesagt, der der Kern des Problems liegt ja dann auch bei der
bevorzugten Behandlungen.
Genau. Und das ist äh kommt in der ganzen Diskussion für meinen Geschmack auch noch ein bisschen zu kurz, auch wenn's immer wieder fällt und äh da kann man sich im Prinzip jetzt auch ja noch ein bisschen mehr drauf,
dass einfach dieser dieser Verkauf von Zugang einfach nicht geht.
Und da will also Rüssel jetzt tatsächlich dran und sagt, äh Netzbetreiber dürfen eigene oder fremd
in fremde Inhalte grundsätzlich nicht bevorzugt übermitteln. Ähm,
Bin ich jetzt mal und die Bundesnetzagentur soll dann gegen Verstöße dagegen vorgehen können. Ich bin mal gespannt, Bundestag und Bundesrat äh müssten das Ganze noch diskutieren. Ähm,
Ich habe den Entwurf noch nicht gesehen und bin mal gespannt, wie der dann genau aussieht. Wir kommen natürlich dann,
Da sofort in die kleinteilige Debatte, weil äh man dann sich eben überlegen muss, okay, was ist mit äh mit Q, US und grundsätzlichen
Netzwerkmanagement um sicher zu gehen, dass alles noch funktioniert, da da ist ja so diese dieses Definitionsproblem bei Netzneutralität. Äh ich bin mal gespannt, wie gut das äh Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
da seine Hausaufgaben macht. Aber um es festzuhalten, der der Knackpunkt ist die bevorzugte Behandlung anderer,
Und als wer sich nur um die um seinen eigenen Internetanschluss sorgt, der sollte trotzdem im Hinterkopf behalten. Das heißt, immer noch, dass eine Leistung den Kunden weggenommen wird. Ja, sie hatten vorher eine Flatrate und die haben sie danach nicht mehr,
und äh das heißt, es ihnen wird eine Leistung weggenommen und eine versteckte Preiserhöhung, weil ihnen ja angeboten wird, ja, wir überlegen uns das mal bis zweitausendsechzehn, da wird's dann nochmal einen teureren Tarif geben äh.
Den Kunden wegnehmen. Es gilt ja zunächst einmal nur für neue Kunden,
Ja, also wir reden ja nicht von Änderungen der Verträge, sondern nur bestimmte Verträge hatten das auch vorher schon drin. Also, ne, VDSL zum Beispiel
hatte das schon drin, diese Drossel, wenn auch nicht mit ähm diesen dreihundertvierundachtzig Kilobit, sondern sechs Megabit, zahle die auch sonst selten genannt wird. Jetzt kommt halt neu ins Feld diese zwei Megabyte äh zwei Megabit
Geschichte,
muss man sehen. Also das ist äh auf jeden Fall alles noch im Fluss und ich würde sagen, da ist das letzte Wort auch noch nicht gesprochen und die Telekom ist diese Drossel äh Klappe nicht los.
So sieht's ja, so sieht's ja auch aus, dass der ähm also du sagst, hast Recht, die die Debatte ist nicht beendet
Erstens kommt jetzt was aus dem Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und dann hat die Bundesnetzagentur ja irgendwie das Ergebnis ihrer Befragung. Wir erinnern uns, wir hatten das ja erwähnt, die Bundesnetzagentur hat einen Fragebogen geschickt,
und ähm sind aber mit den mit den Antworten nicht zufrieden. Das heißt, äh sie sagen, da sind noch viele äh Fragen offen.
Das können wir uns auch gut vorstellen. Naja, schauen wir mal, ob's das Thema durchs Sommerloch äh schafft. Dank Wahlkampf sollte man hier einiges bewegen können.
Ja, äh auch viel äh Aufheben, man hat das Gefühl, eine andere Diskussionsebene gibt's gerade gar nicht, ist halt äh Prison, Logbuch Netzpolitik
äh äh berichtete, also diese Abhörmaßnahmen der NSA in den USA
jetzt auch die eigenen äh Bürger äh umfangreich trifft, die von diesem bekannt gemacht wurden, der hat jetzt zuletzt auch eine ganze Menge weitere Veröffentlichungen gemacht und äh weitere wohl auch noch
angekündigt. Man muss mal schauen, wie viele äh Feinde er sich da äh demnächst noch so macht. Zwischenzeitlich wurde er ja in China schon mal groß gefeiert,
ne? Spielt natürlich den Chinesen wunderbar so in die Hände, ne? Immer wenn sie die ganze Zeit angeklagt, dass sie ja alles behacken,
Was ja auch so ist, ja? Äh nur Snowden meint so, ja, die USA hackt auch zurück, also das hat den äh Chinesen in der Argumentation schon gefehlt.
Ja, endlich sagt's mal einer. Ich meine, bin gespannt, was die nächste Runde gibt so. Also ich schätze mal
ob die Chinesen mit ihm so dauerhaft so glücklich sind, weiß ich nicht, aber jetzt haben sie ihn halt so äh hochgefeiert, dass zumindest die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer unmittelbaren Auslieferung aus Hongkong, wenn man denn überhaupt erstmal seine habhaft werden würde,
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihn irgendjemand wirklich aktiv also suchen tun ihm bestimmt Leute, aber wer jetzt so genau und wie viel Mühe sich die Chinesen da jetzt gerade geben, weiß ich nicht,
Aber unsere Vermutung, dass er da in Hong Kong nicht so sicher ist, die, weiß ich nicht, ob man die so ohne Weiteres aufrechterhalten kann.
Ich frage mich, wann äh in der US-Öffentlichkeit oder vielleicht wurde die Karte auch schon gezogen
dass er da halt grade in China ist und China ist ja offensichtlich beim Hacking der Feind, ne? Also und er ist, man könnte also ich bin mal gespannt, ob man
ob man ihm da nicht noch einen drauf spinnt. Wenn er jetzt da zu eng mit den Chinesen kuschelt, dass sie sagen, ey, hier einer unserer äh Top-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter ähm geht jetzt irgendwie, ist versucht da gerade zu den Chinesen überzuwandern, ne. Also da bin ich bin ich mal.
Ich glaube, es bedarf da sozusagen überhaupt gar kein Ersteigerung mehr. Ich meine, sie könnten ihn jetzt auch schon äh komplett durch den Schlamm ziehen. Das ist jetzt bedarf sozusagen keiner weiteren Argumentation her. Äh mehr nur äh so eine Aushilfe äh Auslieferungsgesuch,
An die Chinesen würde wahrscheinlich generell eher wobei es ist glaube ich sogar so, dass in Hongkong nee ist,
Stimmt, besteht nicht sogar in Hongkong ein Auslieferungsabkommen mit den USA? Glaube ich nämlich auch,
Also es gibt so etwas tatsächlich und also.
Unklar.
Unklar, ja. Äh spannend, wie auch immer. Prison, was kam raus? Die Debatte schwappte auch so ein bisschen nach Deutschland, weil sich natürlich auch die Frage stellt, na ja, was äh ist denn bei uns so? Und dann kam irgendwie der BND und äh,
Was haben die noch mal konkret angekündigt? Das habe ich auch noch so mit einem Auge verfolgt.
Sie haben gesagt, also wir äh haben ja, wir hatten das ja auch schon äh gesagt, das Programm, was sie haben, dass äh die die Abteilung technische Aufklärung des BND. Ähm die hat also jetzt äh äh gesagt, ja wir wollen übrigens ähm
nochmal äh hundert Millionen haben äh für die kommenden fünf Jahre und damit unsere äh technische,
Aufklärung ausbauen, wir bauen irgendwie hundert neue Mitarbeiter,
und äh stärkere Rechen und Serverkapazitäten, um ähm weiterhin hier überwachen zu können,
in einer ersten Trance hat die Bundesregierung den jetzt schon fünf Millionen gegeben. Wer weiß, also naja, okay, ist ein Taufen auf einen heißen Stein,
aber sie wollen ähnlich wie die wie die NSA
den grenzüberschreitenden Datenverkehr möglichst umfassend überwachen und laut Gesetz sind sie dazu berechtigt bis zu zwanzig Prozent
Der Kommunikation zwischen der BRD und dem Ausland auf verdächtige Inhalte zu prüfen. Aber.
Auch eine Drossel.
Sie haben technische Probleme und deswegen schaffen sie's äh bislang nur knapp fünf Prozent,
der E-Mails, Telefonate, Facebook-Konversationen oder Skype-Unterhaltung. Ja, sie wollen aber zwanzig, weil das dürfen sie ja.
Was was ist der Grund für diese haben sie einen Telekomanschluss oder was? Kriegen sie nicht so viel durch, leider gedrosselt worden.
Ähm also es gibt ein schönes Wording. Das ist sehe ich jetzt erst. Der schöne Begriff des Kontrollverlusts äh wird da in
und sagen, sagt, wer sagt das, der Herr ach ja klar. Ihrem Friedrich sagt ähm,
Der Staat muss dafür sorgen, dass wir Kontrollverluste über die Kommunikation von Kriminellen durch neue rechtliche und technologische Mittel
ausgleichen. Also ihr Friedrich hat einen Kontrollverlust, weil er nur fünf Prozent äh kontrollieren kann und er möchte aber gerne an die äh rechtliche Maximalgrenze von zwanzig Prozent heran.
Und ähm die letzte Zahl äh hatten wir auch schon in der letzten Sendung zitiert, was irgendwie knapp drei Millionen E-Mails und SMS äh,
überprüft wurden und da wollen sie natürlich mehr haben,
ja? Das war, das war vorhersehbar, dass sie das machen, also dass sie es ausbauen wollen würden. Äh man fragt sich, äh was die rauchen, dass sie es ausgerechnet jetzt bekannt machen,
also äh man kann sich da auch nur äh an den am äh also ja, aber okay, die sind ja auch Experten für Geheimkommunikation und nicht für öffentliche Kommunikation.
Wo ich mich auch sehr, wo ich mich sehr drüber freue ist, dass ich ja inzwischen, also der, der Uhl, den, den habe ich ja inzwischen so gut drauf, dass ich vorher sagen kann, was der sagen wird, nicht
Woche. Und letzte Woche habe ich ja schon gesagt, dass jetzt gefordert werden wird, dass wir mehr IT-Infrastruktur made in Germany haben,
Uhl und wie viel Spitz ist Verlass? Äh wie viel Spitz von der SPD? Ulf von der von der CSU. Die beiden jungen Herren
die sich oder jungen Herren, die sich
äh mit mit äh Innenpolitik auseinandersetzen und der Ur, den habe ich auch im Innenausschuss äh hat der mir auch seinen Blick zugeworfen, unter dem ich dann zitterte,
und ähm sagt natürlich schön, also ich hatte komplett, hätte ich für den Schreiben äh
können, damit die Kommunikation unseres Staates und unserer Unternehmen kein amerikanischer und erst recht kein chinesischer oder russischer Dienst mitlesen kann, müssen wir unsere eigene Kommunikationstechnik aufbauen
Sei sie nun deutsch oder europäisch, sagt Harbe Uhl und ähm,
Jetzt müssen müssen irgendwie dreistellige Millionenbeträge in IT, made in Germany investiert werden, ja? Ähm.
Und wie viel Spütz von der SPD äh pflichtet ihm bei. Das war äh das war, wie gesagt, vorherzusehen und ähm
zeigt nur, wie wie völlig, also dass das Deutschland halt genau so drauf ist, ja? In einer innerhalb einer Woche, sagt der BND, das gleiche Programm wollen wir bei uns ausbauen,
Uhr setzt sich hin und ja müssen ein bisschen aufpassen und irgendwie schöne Deutschland-Cloud hier machen, damit die Daten nicht bei den US-Diensten landen. Also.
Dann können sie ja endlich mehr IT-Firmen äh alten Flughafengebäude in Tempelhof ansiedeln. Wurde ja auch schon vorgeschlagen.
Also es ist es zeigt nur, dass wir hier äh dass wir hier genau genau das Gleiche machen, äh da brauchen wir uns hier keine äh,
zu machen. Und auch dieses Angela Merkel jetzt, also wir haben ja den Obama, der übrigens, ich stelle fest, Obama wurde noch nicht von der US-Regierung erschossen. Ähm ich habe, es handelte sich um einen Versprecher in der letzten Sendung,
Ich meinte Osama. Wurden also mehrfach auf Twitter darauf hingewiesen.
Ja, na ja, jetzt kommt ja Obama äh nach Berlin. Ich glaube, er wird heute Abend hier nach der Sendung äh eintrudeln.
Sind schon festgeschweißt.
Genau,
Und äh wird dann hier so durch so ein Berlin geführt werden, was irgendwie wohl abgeriegelt äh jegliche Realität von ihm fernhält. Ähm trotzdem,
Drumherum werden sich dann auch noch ein paar Piraten und ich glaube auch die irgendwie noch mit einer eigenen äh äh Demo darum herumscharen. Na ja, sage ich da mal,
Weiß nicht, ob äh ob das jetzt so hilfreich ist, da ähm jetzt die Gelegenheit zu nutzen, auf den auf den USA rumzu äh hämmern, weil das für meinen Geschmack eigentlich nur so den Eindruck erzeugt
wir hätten hier kein Problem und die Probleme legen äh in Übersee.
Ich dachte auch, das wäre eher so ein Thema für die Nazis immer.
Was?
Diese antiamerikanische Propaganda. So und das machen die ja auch ganz gerne.
Ja, da sind ja die Linken auch nicht schlecht. Also das da.
Ja, die nähern sich immer mehr an, ne?
Das ist na ja, ich will das jetzt nicht zu sehr vertiefen. Manchmal äh erschrecken einen die die Gleichnisse, aber die Unterschiede sind auf jeden Fall auch noch da, bevor äh da jetzt auch gleich wieder die passenden Kommentare dazukommen.
Auch immer ja weiß nicht.
Die macht irgendwie Dienstag äh zwölf Uhr. Die sammelt sich, glaube ich, grade am Checkpoint Charlie
und ähm macht dort eine kleine Kundgebung unter dem Motto Yes we scan mit irgendwelchen Kopfhörern und äh und Satellitenschüsseln und so und ähm,
Hat sich dafür den Checkpoint Charlie ausgesucht. Um irgendwie äh Obama.
Sicherzustellen, dass auch genug Leute mit Kameras da sind.
Ja, vielleicht liegt's ja. Man muss ja dazu also es gibt ja immer noch den Hintergrund, dass dass das alles halt Buschprojekte sind, die von Obama ausgebaut wurden. Und das ist natürlich schon
zumindest in den USA etwas worüber man,
ernsthaft mal nachdenken und diskutieren muss, ne? Also das ist schon, denke ich, für die äh für die Obama-Wähler ein äh,
Großes Problem. Und wenn man sich das mal äh also so historisch über die letzten Jahre anschaut, äh einige waren vor vor ein paar Jahren ja noch, ich glaube, das war vor der Wahl, Obamas, als er hier in Berlin zu Besuch war und haben ihn da zugejubelt am
Brandenburger Tor oder wo das war und können oder an der Siegelsäule.
Brandenburger Tor durfte nicht jetzt am Brandenburger Tor, weil jetzt ist er ja auch richtiger Präsident.
Ach so, ah ja auch.
War ja nur Kandidat und kann ja nicht sein, dass hier irgendwelche Kandidaten sich vors Brandenburger Tor stellen, weil wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Okay, also ich ich war da nicht, ich war da nicht beteiligt. Ich habe nur mit einigen gesprochen. Die natürlich jetzt, ne, einige Jahre später äh mit sehr anderen Augen auf diesen Obama äh Besuch blicken, ne.
Ja, ich kann dir zwar auch nur sagen, wenn man glaubt, dass eine einzelne Person,
die dann vielleicht noch so einen Mitarbeiterkreis austauscht, ja? Äh von heute auf morgen den Weg einer Weltmacht äh ändert, dann ist man da glaube ich auch äh einer Illusion
unterliegen, ja? Das ist ein Apparat, der auf so vielen Ebenen da marschiert, das sind das sind einfach große Tanker,
Selbst wenn du das Ding in eine komplett andere Richtung,
ziehen möchtest, dann sitzt du da irgendwie mit deinem Hanfseil in der Hand und äh kannst daran ziehen, wie du willst. Das Ding fährt auch erstmal ein paar Jahre weiter in dieselbe Richtung und äh im besten Fall,
verliert es an Geschwindigkeit. Jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren, dass hier sehr wohl an Geschwindigkeit sogar noch zugelegt wurde, was den Ausbau betrifft.
Ich denke, da wissen wir einfach selber auch zu wenig von den internen Sachen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich alles äh kritikwürdig und deswegen wird es hier auch kritisiert.
Noch ganz kurz auf den, man muss ja auch sich den den Teufelskreis vorstellen, den ähm Terrorismus dann oder überhaupt,
der dann immer dann ausgelöst wird, wenn irgendwo eine Angst um die öffentliche Sicherheit entsteht. Und das ist, das sehen wir ja bei bei unserem Innenminister, bei allen unseren Innenministern, ja, ähm,
oder jetzt auch bei dem bei dem US-Präsidenten oder bei jedem, der da irgendeine Verantwortung trägt, du bist derjenige, der dessen Job es ist, so etwas zu verhindern,
und gleichzeitig ist ganz klar, dass du das nicht kannst,
Du kannst den nicht verhindern, ähm dass also zumindest nicht als Innenminister, ja, vielleicht als Außenminister kannst du äh verhindern oder als Entwicklungshilfeminister kannst du vielleicht dafür sorgen, dass die Welt äh das Land ein bisschen weniger hasst,
Ja oder ähm und und sich nicht mehr motiviert fühlt, dieses Land anzugreifen oder seine Bundesregierung.
Täter könnte man auch als Bundeskanzler oder Bundeskanzlerin schon eine Menge machen, weil letztlich wir wissen ja alle, so Extremismus hat einfach viel mit den generellen Situationen im Land zu tun und nicht nur mit einer äh externen Bedrohung äh.
Genau, du musst mit der, du musst mit einer, du musst die, du musst die Auslöser für diese Menschen,
eindämmen und nicht mit Sicherheitsmethoden versuchen irgendwie sie daran zu hindern, dir die an die Karte zu pissen,
So, das heißt, wer Terrorist ist, wird, wird nicht, wird durch egal welche Maßnahme nicht daran gehindert werden, am Ende etwas,
irgendwie eine terroristische Maßnahme äh zu ergreifen. Das sind aber natürlich sehr, sehr wenige. Nur wenn halt dann einer von denen irgendwann mal etwas macht
dann bist du der Arsch als Innenminister, völlig egal, da stellt keiner mehr eine Frage und sagt, hör mal, vielleicht haben wir einfach seit vierzig Jahren eine eine äh,
Außenpolitik wie wie 'ne offene Hose und sollten uns mal überlegen warum wir noch nicht viel öfter angegriffen werden. Ja also solche solche Fragen stellt dann keiner mehr,
So und äh das heißt.
In der Außenpolitik wie eine offene Hose.
Unhöfliche Außenpolitik, sagen wir mal. So oder oder.
Ich versuche jetzt gleich, die ganzen Bilder, die ich dir grade in meinem Kopf komme.
Heißt das nicht oder wie eine aus äh eine Außenpolitik wie Graf Rotz. So und ähm,
Das heißt, die die Auslöser stellt keiner in Frage. So und äh zum Ende zu kommen. Das heißt, als Innenminister hast du nur diese Mittel. Und wenn du die nicht ergreifst, wirst du dich nachher dafür äh wirst dich nachher dafür rechtfertigen müssen
und es haben nur wenige den,
Arsch in der Hose zu sagen, äh wir wir müssen äh unsere Freiheit hier ausweiten, unsere Gesellschaft offener machen und die Bildung erhöhen,
um sowas zu verhindern. Das haben die ähm,
die einzige Reaktion, die ich so gesehen habe, war, als der wies dieser dieser Irre, der da auf der Insel rummarschiert ist,
Also auf den hat die die, die da betroffene Regierung reagiert. Aber sonst siehst du sowas gar nicht, sondern Innenminister, natürlich bauen die alles aus. Willst du nicht am Ende sagen, du hättest deinen Job nicht gemacht, du bist Innenminister.
Ja, da haste, haste auch so die Kacke zu hauen.
Das ist der Innenminister, das ist die Aufgabe des Innenministers oder das ist die fallende.
Dieser Aufgabe kommt, kommen die Innenminister in Deutschland ja auch durchaus nach, aber es könnte auch alles viel schlimmer sein. So, lass mal hier äh das Thema abwickeln. Haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges äh.
Es kam noch die Meldung, das war nur am Rande, dass bei dieser EU-Datenschutzverordnung, die ja jetzt auch immer noch heiß diskutiert wird, äh dass es da äh US-Lobby ihn gab, um eine Klausel zu verhindern
die denen, die genau diese NSA-Zugriffe äh verboten hätte,
Also da da ich habe das nur kurz als Meldung gelesen. Da ging's also darum, dass dass die USA stark dafür gelobbyt haben, dass die EU Daten äh
Schutzverordnung diesen Zugriff nicht ausschließt und gleichzeitig haben auch die US-Unternehmen dafür lobbyiert, weil die ja wiederum von den USA dafür verpflichtet sind. Und wenn es da hart auf hart gekommen wäre, fürchteten sie.
Da einen Link auf Lobby-Plug, wo aus dem das so hervorgeht, das wäre ja mal in.
Genau den gibt's nicht, genau diesen diesen Link gibt's nicht, sondern das scheint quasi schon stattgefunden zu haben äh vor der ähm.
Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt wurde. So. Und woher kommt dann dieses Gerücht her, dass ja jetzt viel Konjunktiv? Wir nennen keine Quellen. Oh, guck mal, du da hinten.
Also Quelle ist die Financial Times.
Ah okay, dann nehmen die.
Aber eine Paywall hat, deswegen nehme ich da eine.
Verstehe. Ist gut, mit so PayVals kann man alles Mögliche äh behaupten, ne? Ja, die Financial Times hat ja auch gesagt.
Man denn hier äh.
Ja, könnt ihr euch leider nicht angucken, kostet Geld.
Ich möchte free, ich selector free. Ja, okay, also, äh, muss man trotzdem sichern. Meine Güte.
Was dachtest du denn?
Naja, wo ist das mit den Quellen, ne? Wenn immer teurer. Gut, äh, haben wir's, oder? Genau, demnächst äh mehr und besser recherchiert.
Wenn ich mal weniger Tränengas im Gesicht habe.
Genau. Ja, kommen wir noch mal zu äh unserem Gast und den damit äh verbundenen Thema. Wir hatten das ja hier schon ein paar Mal auch schon ähm genannt, C drei äh S,
Haben wir uns neulich irgendwie auf einer Party getroffen oder und äh
Da meinte ich so zu mir, sei schon wieder alles anders, also anders als sich das zum Beispiel bei dem entsprechenden Vortrag auf dem letzten Kongress neunundzwanzig C drei in Hamburg ähm,
zugetragen hat. Da gab's ja verschiedene Vertreter. Da war's aber jetzt, glaube ich, nicht da auf der Bühne, ne, genau,
Ähm und äh ich dachte mir so, wer doch mal vielleicht eine gute Gelegenheit, das Thema dann auch mal mit dem Insider neu,
aufzugreifen. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu,
dir, vielleicht kannst du ja mal kurz sagen, was eigentlich so dein äh hintergrund so generell ist, was machst du und was,
Ist dann auch deine Rolle in diesem C3 S Spielchen.
Also ich bin äh schon sehr lange Musiker,
Also seit meiner Kindheit sozusagen und äh wollte das auch immer machen und war auch lange Energie immer Mitglied vierzehn Jahre,
Und als ich dann äh Creative Commons Lizenzen benutzen wollte,
Wurde mir halt nahegelegt, dass ich dann ja austreten müsse, weil die gehe mal auf keinen Fall das äh erlaubt und ähm ich da auch nicht irgendwelche Sachen ausnehmen kann sozusagen und äh da war ich schon etwas äh überrascht, weil ich dachte immer, die arbeiten für mich, aber,
Das war ähm zweitausendvier.
Okay, schon eine Weile her.
Und dann äh bin ich halt ausgetreten, das dauert ja auch immer eine Weile, bis man dann endgültig draußen ist aus der GEMA. Zwei Jahre ungefähr, so ziemlich genau und ähm.
Seit zwei Jahren bist du nicht mehr Mitglied.
Nee, also zwei Jahre dauert das bis zu quasi tatsächlich nicht mehr Mitglied bist. Die Kündigungsfrist.
Ach so, ja genau, beziehungsweise äh sagt die Klausel nicht auch, dass du in dem Zeitraum gab's noch Einschränkungen, was diese zwei Jahresfrist betrifft. Du darfst dann gar nichts auch publizieren oder gibt's nicht so eine Publikationsverbot oder so?
Theoretisch also ich bin da nicht so sicher, weil ich habe da ähm generell äh mich nicht drum gekümmert. So, ich habe äh ganz viele Sachen unter Pseudonym veröffentlicht und so.
Das darfst du gar nicht sagen. So, aber nicht das Pseudonym.
Natürlich. Natürlich.
Also wir hatten das doch glaube ich behandelt. Die wollen damit verhindern, dass du irgendwie so GEMA on off hopst. Gamer hopping machst und deswegen gilt diese Gamervermutung noch zwei Jahre weiter für dich.
Ja also ähm Doktor Motte hat mal in einem Interview gesagt, das wäre so, dass wenn du irgendwie dann einen Monat später was veröffentlichst, äh an dem du kompositorisch oder als Autor beteiligt bist, das dann quasi seine Kündigungsfrist sich auch verlängert.
Ach du Scheiße, der ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ne, also du kommst dann quasi gar nicht raus theoretisch. Da weiß ich aber nicht, ob das tatsächlich so ist. Ähm ähm es war auf jeden Fall ähm.
Klingt alles sehr rechtsstaatlich.
Ziemlich ätzend und äh,
Ich habe dann auch äh ein paar Jahre mich damit beschäftigt, die GEMA öffentlich anzuklagen und dieses ganze äh System, das ich auch selber erstmal hinterfragt, weil ich dann schon äh,
zugeben muss, dass als Musiker, wenn du so aktiv bist, bist da einfach Mitglied, weil irgendwie wird da jeder Mitglied. Das wird ja eigentlich auch.
So, ja genau, macht man so.
Äh vom vom Label oder wenn du einen Vertrag unterschreibst oder natürlich, wenn du einen Verlag hast oder einen Vorschuss haben möchtest, musst du natürlich an Mitglied sein, weil sonst kommt der Verlag ja nicht an sein Geld,
du bezahlst das mit ihm in Ratenzahlung oder so, aber,
Ja und ähm habe dann mich auch beteiligt an diesem Copy-Cen-Projekt damals mit ein paar Leuten zusammen irgendwie überlegt, wie könnte man das denn dann machen? Äh,
Das ist einfach fair.
Nochmal Copy kennen.
War so eine Art Crowdfunding, bevor es den Begriff so gab in der Öffentlichkeit, sage ich mal. Also es war eigentlich so die Idee, dass man Spenden einsammelt für eine Veröffentlichung im Grunde genommen, ne? So konnte sich ein Preview angucken,
Man könnte sagen, ja, ich habe hier was, das würde ich gerne ausproduzieren, dafür brauche ich Geld und dann konnte man sammeln. Sozusagen und das hat sich aber überhaupt nicht durchgesetzt. Das war, glaube ich, einfach auch ein bisschen früh dafür,
und äh habe dann halt so Vorträge gehalten öfter mal darüber und habe dann halt immer hier mal erzählt, dass äh das mit der GEMA irgendwie nicht so toll ist, wie das da läuft und so und ein bisschen ungerecht oder ein bisschen sehr ungerecht,
Verteilung der Gelder und auch sehr intransparent und so und das weiß man ja jetzt im allgemeinen mittlerweile,
viele Medienberichterstattungen, die da gelaufen ist, auch wegen der Gebührenerhöhung, die sie machen wollten, die in diesem Jahr für die Klubs und so,
Und ähm als im Jahre zweitausendzehn die Popcom ausgefallen ist wegen der ganzen bösen Downloader, hatte sich damals ja die.
Ach ja, ich erinnere.
Das erste Mal und.
Also eine alternative Veranstaltung hier in äh Berlin.
Genau und da gab's einige interessante Panels und so und äh da war unter anderem auch äh eins äh Creative Commes Verwertungsgesellschaft. Ja oder nein oder brauchen wir das? Möchten wir das haben und so und dann wurde sich drüber unterhalten. Da habe ich mich dann auch dazu gesetzt,
weil das finde ich natürlich sehr interessant war, weil ich damals ja mich quasi von meiner Einnahmequelle GEMA verabschieden musste, um freie Lizenzen benutzen zu dürfen,
Ne, also ich habe gerade so gesagt, äh okay, dann nehmt doch mein Geld und ich verzichte darauf,
zu sagen und äh dann darf ich endlich freie Lizenzen benutzen und das kam mir schon ziemlich beschissen vor. Also ich fand das nicht in Ordnung eigentlich, aber,
ja, so war's halt. Ich musste das so machen und dachte dann aber es wäre eigentlich ganz schön, wenn's endlich mal eine Alternative gäbe zur GEMA, weil das einfach nicht sein kann, dass es da nur eine Verwertungsgesellschaft gibt für ähm öffentliche Aufführungen und mechanische Verfältigungen,
und ähm da wurde dann auch darüber geredet, dass es ja vielleicht ganz schön wäre, wenn es für Verwertungsgesellschaft gebe und da haben sich die Creative Comics Deutschland Leute auch dran beteiligt, also Weizmann war da und.
Wer ist das? Entschuldigung.
John Weißmann, das ist doch der ähm glaube ich Creative Commons Deutschland.
Loyer.
Ja oder auf jeden Fall einer von den.
Also ist der ähm S, glaube ich, äh Anwalt ähm und ein, ich glaube, im Vorstand äh hat da irgendwie juristisch die die,
Handball Creative Comments. Bei dem kleinen Creative Comments-Verein in Deutschland, der ja, glaube ich, erstmal nicht viel mehr macht, als diese Lizenzen dann äh so zu übersetzen, dass sie in Deutschland äh auch Sinn sinnvoll sind.
Ja und Rechtssicherheit haben, ne? Und äh da war dann relativ bald klar, dass also sie werden's nicht machen, selbst und würden es aber natürlich auch schön finden und ähm,
nach mehreren Jahren, in denen ich hoffte, es würde sich irgendwie von alleine irgendwas gründen, ist mir dann halt klar geworden, dass es da ähm,
Ja, Eigeninitiative braucht und äh als ich dann merkte, nach dieser dass sich da was konkretisiert und dass es tatsächlich ein paar Leute gibt, die das jetzt in Angriff nehmen wollen aus dem Bereich des Open Music Contest und ähm,
halt auch ähm Musiker oder Leute, die eher wirtschaftlich mit Musik zu tun haben,
da habe ich mich den einfach angeschlossen und dachte das ist gut, das unterstütze ich, finde ich 'ne super Sache und seitdem beteilige ich mich daran sozusagen.
Aber jetzt kommen natürlich die die blöde Frage, die dir sicherlich oft anhören muss, wenn du vorher in der GEMA warst, dann hast du doch wurdest du doch von der GEMA, hast du doch das das schöne ganze Geld bekommen, deine Lebensgrundlage, deine deine
Porsches und Ferraris dir von dem Geld gekauft? Wie willst du das weitermachen mit den offenen Lizenzen? Oder wie wie ging es dir danach?
Also ich sage mal so, es ist ja mit der GEMA immer so, es kommt drauf an, was du gerade so machst, ob du jetzt viel oder wenig Geld verdienst. Ich war ja auch nur ähm,
angeschlossenes Mitglied, also eins vom untersten Stand sozusagen, wo am wenigsten Geld landet. Und ähm,
Ja, ich habe einfach äh in erster Linie gar nicht darüber nachgedacht, wie ich äh jetzt in Zukunft mein Geld verdiene. Ich habe ähm lange versucht, einfach so äh Spendenbuttons auf den Webseiten ähm wo ich mein Zeug so hinlege,
reinzubasteln und dann zu hoffen, dass da mal was rumkommt, habe mich aber auch also ich bin ziemlich faul, was das angeht. Ich mache jetzt keine große Werbung und versuche, das irgendwie zu optimieren,
so ein bisschen der typische Künstler Nerd, der eigentlich jemanden braucht, der ihn an die Hand nimmt, damit er auch mal was zu essen kriegt.
Weil er einfach irgendwie jetzt grade ich muss unbedingt Musik machen und äh,
überhaupt keine Lust auch auf dieses schleimige Geschäft und äh dieser Arschkriecherei und Klinken putzen, das lag mir noch nie. Ich fand's schon,
Empfand schon als Nötigung, wenn ich jetzt auf irgendwelche Partys gehen muss, um da mich sehen zu lassen oder um Gespräche führen zu müssen mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die mir vielleicht weiterhelfen können, also das Ganze.
Du bleibst lieber im Keller und äh machst deinen Jam.
Ja, ach äh ich weiß nicht, ich habe mehr Spaß daran gehabt, äh öffentlich mich aufzuregen über die ganze Scheiße, sage ich mal, als irgendwie mich darum zu kümmern, dass ich ein Brot auf den Tisch kriege oder so,
und ähm die Tatsache, dass ich jetzt mich daran beteilige, eine neue Verwertungsgesellschaft mitzugründen, ist eigentlich äh eher darauf zurückzuführen, dass ich halt,
versuche, mich ein bisschen zu ändern. Also irgendwie zu gucken, dass die ganzen Gelder, die da fließen tatsächlich ja auch für ähm,
Künstler, die jetzt meinetwegen zum Beispiel auch nicht in der GEMA Mitglied sind, es werden ja Gelder gezahlt für Dinge, die diese Menschen produzieren,
aber nieder ankommen, weil die halt im im Sack pennen und ähm das das zu ändern ist so eines der Anliegen, das ich da habe, so einfach.
Wir hatten das, glaube ich, schon mal behandelt. Äh ich wollte jetzt auch gerade die Episode rausholen, hab's aber nicht auf die Schnelle gefunden.
Vielleicht kannst du mal ganz kurz erklären, wie das ist mit dieser mit dieser mit den verschiedenen Ständen, die man als GEMA-Mitglied erreichen kann. Es gibt ja die, die unteren Mitglieder, die weder Stimmrecht haben,
noch äh gleiche Beteiligung, das heißt also irgendwie, es gibt, je, je, je voller und vollwertiger deine GEMA-Mitgliedschaft ist,
desto mehr Rechte hast du dort auf den äh also desto mehr Stimmrecht oder dann hast du überhaupt mein Stimmrecht und du bekommst auch mehr Geld, ne?
Ja, also du hast äh nur als ordentliches Mitglied ein Stimmrecht. Das sind ungefähr fünf Prozent der Mitglieder der GEMA.
Sechstausend Leute, ne.
Ja und ähm also die anderen zwei Gruppen, also die angeschlossenen außerordentlichen Mitglieder haben auch Stimmrecht indirekt, sie werden durch Delegierte vertreten,
So und das muss man auf jeden Fall mal deutlich sagen, weil es wird oft so dargestellt, als wäre die GEMA äh so strukturiert, dass die wirklich überhaupt kein Stimmrecht haben, das stimmt natürlich nicht.
Und ähm es ist aber schon so, dass da einfach keine Mehrheiten entstehen können, weil einfach die ja, die mit direktem Stimmrecht äh einfach auch diejenigen sind, die am meisten verdienen, innerhalb der GEMA,
Du kannst sowieso erst ordentliches Mitglied werden, wenn du eine gewisse Summe übersteigst, die verdienst, also es so, dass halt wirklich die Gutverdiener.
Der Grad an Stimmkraft sozusagen hängt davon ab, wie reich man schon geworden ist damit. Wenn man viel kriegt, dann darf man auch viel beeinflussen.
So ungefähr, ja, also es ist so, dass diejenigen nur ordentliches Mitglied werden, die tatsächlich äh nachweislich professionell äh und zum Lebensunterhalt äh Musik machen,
oder Texte schreiben,
die sollen auch am meisten äh mitbestimmen dürfen, weil es ja nur gerecht ist sozusagen, nach dieser Vorstellung, dass diejenigen, die das Geld generieren, dass die halt auch darüber entscheiden, wie das alles äh geregelt wird.
Ist aber auch logisch, dass die dann natürlich äh Strukturen so bauen, dass,
Dass sichergestellt ist, dass sie weiterhin auch Geld bekommen, oder? Also das das scheint diese es gibt doch da irgendwie, wenn man jetzt unabhängig von der Struktur nur den, den Umverteilungsschlüssel anschaut, ist es doch
meine ich so, dass äh bevorzugt oder dass man eher Geld bekommt, als,
Äh je, je wichtiger,
Je wichtiger man als Mitglied ist. Also statt zu sagen, je mehr meine Lieder gespielt werden, desto weniger Geld bekomme ich pro,
Pro ähm pro äh Mal, dass es gespielt wird, äh wird's genau umgekehrt gemacht und gesagt, geh weniger mein Lied gespielt wird, desto weniger Geld bekomme ich pro,
Aufführung, so dass ihr so habe ich das, glaube ich, verstanden. Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ob das richtig ist, dass du quasi erst eine eine bestimmte Menge an Aufführungen bekommen musst, damit du überhaupt Geld bekommst und an dieser Erhebung ja so komisch ist oder oder ist das jetzt Unsinn?
Das kann ich dir so genau gar nicht beantworten. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Unsinn ist. Es ist so ähm,
Das ist natürlich dadurch, dass unheimlich viele Gelder ähm kassiert werden, die ja auch nicht direkt zuzuordnen sind
Ne, weil durch Pauschalen und so, ne? Und da wurde natürlich gesagt, okay, äh wir haben jetzt diejenigen, die in der Regel am meisten ähm gespielt werden oder am bekanntesten sind, chart, Interpreten oder was auch immer. Und die bekommen dann natürlich irgendwie aus diesen,
Topf,
des äh nicht zuorden warnen äh baren Geldes, was fließt äh dann ihren Anteil sozusagen und das wird dann immer wieder so äh hochgerechnet wahrscheinlich.
Und ähm ja, das ist natürlich äh sage ich mal, auch nicht mehr so richtig zeitgemäß, weil man ja durchaus,
mittlerweile durch technologische Mittel irgendwie ganz gut. Ja. Ähm feststellen kann, was tatsächlich äh gespielt wird oder so.
Und kann die ganzen, sagen wir mal, alternativen Musikclubs oder so, die halt nicht äh
Chart Musik spielen, die haben wahrscheinlich diese pauschalen Verträge und und
Das heißt, das Geld, was von denen kommt, unterliegt an dieser Hochrechnung, das heißt, da haben wir beispielsweise die gesamte Berliner Techno-Szene. So sieht der nicht die einzelnen Stücke meldet, sondern Pauschalen zahlt, äh unterstützt damit nicht die Interpreten, die da aufgelegt werden.
Oder würde das nicht machen, wenn sie Pauschalen zahlen würde? Ich weiß es ja nicht, weil wie die zahlen. Also das wäre jetzt eine Nummer.
Gut, äh,
Wir können jetzt uns viel noch über diese GEMA-Details äh verlieren. Ich würde natürlich jetzt sehr viel mehr interessieren,
wie geht's da weiter? Also was willst du noch nicht gesagt haben? Du hast dich ja dann auch diesem C3 S Zug äh angeschlossen. Was ist deine Aufgabe da in dem.
Ich bin so äh Artist am Wasserdor sozusagen. Also ich,
versuche Künstler nun irgendwie dieses Konzept nahe zu legen äh zu bringen und darüber zu informieren, dass wir uns halt gründen wollen jetzt und äh was dahinter steht und sozusagen ein bisschen unter den
Kollegen und Kolleginnen irgendwie einfach mal so ein bisschen das Wort verbreiten. Und ähm.
Die.
Dafür zu gewinnen, uns vielleicht zu unterstützen oder gar Mitglied zu werden.
Schon,
ein paar Mal erwähnt, ja? Und ich erinnere mich noch jetzt gerade im Nachgang zum Kongress, da äh gab's ja dann auch quasi den äh den Aufruf, doch eine Absichtserklärung äh,
Abzugeben, damit sich eben irgendwann mal so diese potenzielle Gruppe von Leuten finden lässt. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, unserem letzten Gespräch,
Als ich das nicht unbedingt jetzt als der tragbare Weg herausgestellt aus rechtlichen Gründen, sondern.
Nee, da ging's.
Nötig Mitglied zu werden, auch äh.
Es ist so, dass wir ähm wir dachten, ursprünglich es wäre vielleicht ganz gut in ein Crowdfunding zu veranstalten, um,
gleich als Genossenschaftsmitglieder zu generieren sozusagen, ähm wo jeder ähm dann Anteile zeichnen kann ähm und dann automatisch quasi Genossenschaftsmitglied werden würde und wir uns dann gründen könnten,
Und es hat sich aber ähm rausgestellt, dass es besser ist, wenn wir die Genossenschaft erstmal gründen,
und danach ein Crowdfunding veranstalten, um Mitglieder zu gewinnen,
Das kann ich dir nicht genau sagen. Ich weiß, ich glaube, es hat rechtlichen einen rechtlichen Hintergrund oder dient einfach auch der Vermeidung von Komplikationen hinterher. Durch den Prozess sozusagen, äh das Crowdfundings, gleichzeitig die Genossenschaftsgründung zu machen, ähm,
anscheinend irgendwie Schwierigkeiten bringen oder so.
Wegen der Kopplung und so weiter und man ist ja noch gar kein richtiger Rechtskörper und.
Genau. Und um das zu vermeiden,
Ist das jetzt mal ganz klar getrennt und äh es wird also erst die Körperschaft sozusagen gegründet, die europäische Genossenschaft, oft äh als die wir das Ganze gründen wollen, ähm damit es eben auch gleich eine europäische Dimension hat,
man nicht äh zum Beispiel dann Gegenseitigkeitsverträge mit anderen Verwertungsgesellschaften abschließen muss, sondern dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass sich in jedem europäischen Land,
sozusagen äh eine Gruppe, die dann beitreten würde.
Lass uns mal, lass uns vielleicht nochmal von vorne auf zu aufrollen. Also, die C drei S ist eine Organisation, die sich im Prinzip gründen will, dafür aber noch Mitglieder braucht.
Genau, im Moment ähm.
Geht's da um eine Zahl, eine bestimmte Zahl.
Ja, wir brauchen ähm also für die Gründung einer europäischen Genossenschaft brauchst du äh dreißigtausend Euro.
Es geht also um Geld und nicht so sehr um dreißigtausend Euro, was einmalig.
Ja, das ist halt irgendwie für die Gründung einer Genossenschaft musst du dieses Geld auf den Tisch legen. So wie bei der GmbH, muss man auch genau, also du.
Sowie bei der GmbH muss man auf der Bank liegen. Und das ist schon ein Problem jetzt.
Ist hoffentlich kein Problem, also wir haben ja regen Zuspruch und wir sind jetzt am im Moment dabei ähm sozusagen die Gründung der Genossenschaft äh voranzutreiben und.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen kein Spendengeld, sondern das muss in Form von Beitritten erfolgen.
Genau, also es müssen Anteile gezeichnet werden.
Aha. Und das kann im Prinzip jeder machen oder können das nur Leute tun, die dann auch potentielle,
Künstler sind, die da was zu melden haben oder äh kann jetzt jeder sagen, och, wird schon immer mal Genosse werden,
Genossenschaft bei ja? Weil das verstehe ich selber auch nicht so. Also ist es.
Im Prinzip kann jeder äh Mitglied der Genossenschaft werden. Ähm da wir halt dann aber eine Verwertungsgesellschaft für ähm Werke der der Tonkunst sind, ne ähm es ist natürlich so, dass wir wollen in erster Linie Musiker aufnehmen,
und Textdichter, die halt aktiv sind als Musiker und wir wollen zum Beispiel nicht Verlage aufnehmen,
Ne und det äh es kann aber trotzdem natürlich ein Verleger hingehen und sagen, ich möchte irgendwie unterstützendes Mitglied dieser Genossenschaft werden.
Also Fördermitglied.
Ein Fördermitglied, ähm der dann kein äh Stimmrecht hat in dem Sinne, aber er könnte das Projekt fördern, wenn er das für richtig befindet, ne? Also.
Was ist mit Podcaster? Also Tonkunst ist ja nun weit äh.
Ja, also ich meine, du äh produzierst ja genau, das ist irgendwie machst du auch Musik eigentlich?
Ich singe ab und zu mal so zwischendurch ein bisschen. Aber ich.
Da ist die Schöffungshöhe wahrscheinlich noch nie.
So, ja, ja,
Nee, die Schöpfungshöhe ist da nicht erreicht. Nee, aber äh das ist halt auch meine eine meiner Fragen, die ich äh habe, also weil es geht ja dadrum, Rechte wahrzunehmen,
bezieht sich das jetzt nur auf Rechte in einer Weiterveröffentlichung oder was also könnte das sozusagen Radio überhaupt mit erfassen oder ist das einfach was anderes?
Hier wird nicht komponiert und hier wird keine wenn.
Nee, also erstmal.
Nach äh gesungen.
Also in erster Linie werden,
die Mitglieder Künstler sein, also Musiker, Musiker oder Textdichter, die halt tatsächlich Musik machen. So, wir wollen das später erweitern, um auch andere Bereiche,
Bild äh Wort, was auch immer, also alles, was derzeit ja auch unter Creative Comics oder anderen freien Lizenzen veröffentlicht wird, äh wollen wir natürlich irgendwann mal auch,
unter einen Hut bringen, aber da es ein sehr großer Aufwand ist, das überhaupt erstmal,
zu coden, sage ich mal, auch irgendwie das äh ins Leben zu rufen ähm haben wir gesagt, wir fangen mit der Musik an.
Und wenn das irgendwie unter Dach und Fach ist.
Ja gut, aber die Musik betrifft ja sozusagen auch Leute, die Radio machen, weil die ja auch das Problem haben, dass sie ja diese Musik gerne lizensieren würden, die es da draußen gibt, um sie zu verwenden. Da sind wir ja im Prinzip genau wieder in diesem Punkt
nur dass es halt keine akzeptablen Modelle gibt, dieses zu tun. Denkst du, dass die C3S an der Stelle auch.
Das wird sich durch die äh Existenz äh auf jeden Fall ändern und das ist auch äh wünschenswert, dass das passiert, ne, weil ähm,
Ja, natürlich ähm werden Podcaster und die C3S dann äh unter Umständen auch ein Geschäftsverhältnis eingehen und äh man wird sich da,
irgendwie äh ja, miteinander beschäftigen und auseinandersetzen müssen und äh ist auch gut so und ähm ich glaube, dass.
Das ist ja ein echtes Problem der Zeit so. Also es ist ja gar nicht möglich, so GEMA äh äh Musik jetzt im großen Stil da äh unterzubringen, weil es gibt zwar da aus alten Zeiten irgendwie mal so ein Podcast,
Modus bei der GEMA, der aber so völlig absurd ist mit irgendwie
dann der Sendung darf nicht länger als eine halbe Stunde sein und muss da irgendwie draufquatschen und also alle möglichen Reglementierungen, die im Prinzip ein freies Format komplett verhindern. Also das ist einfach äh sinnlos. Ich,
versuchen, das zu verstehen, ob ob das sozusagen etwas ist, was die C drei S dann auch übernehmen könnte.
Davon gehe ich mal aus, ja.
Davon gehst du aus. Das ist ja auch so und das haben wir ja hier auch schon mal besprochen, dass äh der also ist ja rein juristisch,
durchaus jetzt auch schon so vorgesehen ist, dass es mehr als eine Gesellschaft gibt, die
diesen Bereich beackern kann und dass diese äh sagenumwobene GIMA Vermutung, also diese Annahme, die von der GEMA regelmäßig ins Feld geführt wird, mit,
Ihr spielt da Musik, also können wir davon ausgehen, dass uns das äh dass das sozusagen in unseren Geschäftsbereich fällt, dass die nur dann möglich ist, wenn es eben auch nur eine solche Organisation gibt und das in dem Moment, wo eine zweite Organisation existiert,
dass sich automatisch ändern würde.
Das ist nach meinem Rechtsverständnis muss das so sein, ja, also weil diese Gamervermutung natürlich nur dann logischerweise aufrechtzuerhalten ist, wenn's eben nur die GEMA gibt.
Ne, weil wenn's zwei gibt, dann wär's ja ein bisschen unfair, dann könntest ja auch eine C drei S Vermutung geben. Und äh das wäre Quatsch. Also, in dem Moment, wo wir,
Gesellschaften haben, ähm müssen die miteinander arbeiten und dann kann nicht eine hingehen und überall erstmal eine Rechnung schreiben, ne, das ist ja dann eigentlich äh,
sozusagen nicht mehr möglich.
Jetzt hast du aber vorhin schon angedeutet, dass es hier auch eine europäische Dimension gibt. Kannst du das nochmal kurz erläutern, weil die GEMA ist ja in dem Sinne keine europäische Organisation, sondern die bezieht sich ja ausschließlich auf Deutschland.
Die ist ähm ein deutscher Verein, der in Deutschland äh registriert ist und hat mit anderen Verwertungsgesellschaften in Europa dann ähm,
Gegenseitigkeitsverträge. Das heißt also, die sagen irgendwie, wenn von euch was,
bei uns läuft, dann leiten wir das an euch weiter, das Geld, wir nehmen das sozusagen dann treu händerisch ein und es wird dann verteilt und wir nehmen dann irgendwie von der und der Firma, deren Künstler die Rechte hier für Deutschland war,
aber die sind äh eine deutsch ein deutscher Verein. Und bei uns äh ist der Plan,
Dass wir eben als europäische und genossenschaft uns gründen, damit es eben möglich ist, wenn ich ein französischer Musiker bin, äh kann ich Mitglied der Genossenschaft werden und ähm,
Kann meine äh meine Rechte wahrnehmen lassen in ganz Europa von einer Verwertungsgesellschaft, die halt in ganz Europa tätig ist,
Das erscheint uns sehr sinnvoll, als Rechtsrahmen und äh weil einem auch durch das,
gleich Mitbestimmungsrecht, also jeder, jedes Mitglied hat ein Stimmrecht und ähm dadurch ist,
eine optimale Demokratisierung des ganzen Urheberrechtssystems oder beziehungsweise des Wahrnehmungssystems für uns gegeben, sodass wir sagen können, ja ähm das ist gerecht, jeder hat das gleiche Recht mitzubestimmen,
und das gilt eben nicht nur ähm hier halt für deutsche Musiker, sondern es soll halt gleich äh auf europäischer Ebene passieren.
Das heißt, letztendlich greift ihr nicht nur die oder also ist eure, euer Gründungs äh Vorhaben. Äh nicht nur irgendwie ein,
Ja, sage ich mal, Angriff auf die auf die Feuerschaft der GEMA, sondern eigentlich auch auf die Feuerschaft der ganzen GEMA
Äquivalent in allen anderen europäischen Ländern.
Also begreifen die nicht an die GEMA, weil eigentlich ist sie.
Ich meine jetzt nicht.
Konzept ist ja erstmal uninteressant, was die GEMA macht oder dass es die gibt oder so, sondern ähm wir wollen einfach.
Also ihr schafft 'ne Alternative zu denen. Das das werten die das ist natürlich ein Angriff. Also.
Das können die so sehen, aber ich glaube, also die haben ja sogar auf ihrer eigenen Seite äh über uns berichtet, auch relativ neutral. Also die GEMA hat auf ihrer eigenen Webseite ihre Mitglieder davon in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass dass wir uns gründen wollen.
Aha.
Und ähm ja.
Wann wann war das.
Und da wir uns ja auch mit, also wir müssen ja dann zusammenarbeiten natürlich auch, wenn das tatsächlich dazu kommt, dass wir eine Zulassung bekommen vom deutschen Patent und Magen am Markenamt für die Tätigkeit, dann äh müssen wir uns mit der GEMA natürlich auch,
an einen Tisch setzen und miteinander auskommen. Insofern ähm liegt es jetzt nicht in unserem Interesse, diese ganze ja,
Polemik gegen die GEMA irgendwie mitzumachen, sondern wir wollen ganz konstruktiv einfach eine Alternative bieten. Äh und,
Das ist so das Hauptanliegen. Einfach zu sagen.
Also ich kann mir da nicht vorstellen, dass die GEMA ernsthaft Bock hat
Erstens ihre äh Gamervermutung äh abschmieren zu sehen und zweitens äh irgendwie noch ein bürokratischen Overhead zu bekommen, weil sie sich die ganze Zeit mit euch auseinandersetzen müssen. Also ich.
Bock haben die vielleicht nicht drauf, aber das ist nunmal so in in dieser Gesellschaft, dass sie sich damit dann einfach abfinden werden müssen.
Deswegen meinte ich also Angriff, Angriff jetzt nicht im, also im Sinne von äh Marktanteile.
Lassen wir vielleicht mal die, die geh mal trotzdem nochmal
so ein bisschen raus, weil erstens, ich finde diesen Artikel nicht, den du da sagst, ich finde jetzt hier nur so eine Pressemitteilung, wo mal so ein Panel irgendwie aufgezählt wird, wo jemand vom C3S äh dabei war,
Würde mich mal interessieren, dieser Link. Äh europäische Genossenschaft habe ich nochmal kurz nach, ist ja ein relativ neues Instrument. Das gibt's äh laut Wikipedia seit achtzehnten August zweitausendsechs,
basiert also auf europäischen Recht,
vorher gab's das sozusagen gar nicht und das ist jetzt quasi von euch der gewählte Weg äh erstmal diese Rechtsform überhaupt ins Leben zu rufen. Die gibt es aber jetzt,
Noch nicht.
Genossenschaft ist noch nicht gegründet.
Und die soll aber quasi gegründet werden. Ihr würdet es morgen machen, wenn was genau gegeben wäre.
Ja, wir brauchen natürlich äh Anteilszeichner. Ne, also das heißt im Moment sind wir dabei ähm Leute zu suchen, die mit uns gemeinsam dieses Gründungskapital.
Hier geht's aber nur um eine einmalige Zahlung, noch nicht unbedingt um eine Verpflichtung auf einem Mitgliedschaft oder bedeutet das, dass man dann auch,
sein muss und dann regelmäßige Beträge abführt. Oder ist das davon nochmal separat? Also heißt jetzt,
Anteilseigner automatisch Mitglied im Sinne von regelmäßige Beiträge oder ist das jetzt eher so ein Spendending mit ja fünfhundert Euro könnt ihr haben tue ich mit rein in den Topf und dann äh habe ich auch erstmal Ruhe.
Ja, also du, wir müssen erstmal die Genossenschaft gründen. Wir sind ja dann noch keine Verwertungsgesellschaft, ne? Also man ist dann Mitglied einer Genossenschaft,
Und ähm hat Anteile gezeichnet, die man natürlich zurückbekommt, wenn man dann wieder austreten möchte. Ne, also ähm man ist dann noch nicht Mitglied dieser ähm Verwertungsgesellschaft, die die Genossenschaft ins Leben rufen will.
Sozusagen diese diese Mitgliedschaft in der Genossenschaft beinhaltet per se jetzt auch erstmal keine regelmäßigen Zahlungen.
Also letztendlich nur in also im Prinzip Crowdfunding dieser dreißigtausend.
Also wir, genau, also es ist jetzt ähm ja, ein Crowdfunding, um um Mitglieder äh zu bekommen, machen wir hinterher, nachdem wir uns gegründet haben und ähm es ist jetzt nicht direkt ein Crowdfunding, weil wir jetzt nicht irgendwie aufrufen.
Geld zu spenden und dann hat man nichts damit zu tun, sondern es geht dadrum, Genossenschaftsgründungsmitglieder zu finden und wie erfolgreich seid ihr da jetzt schon? Also ich meine, wie viel fehlt da noch? Gibt's da irgendwie eine Zahl? Gibt's da irgendwie.
Da gibt's keine Zahl im Moment, wir haben Kandidaten, die wir angesprochen haben oder noch ansprechen werden in den nächsten Tagen,
Und ähm ich, so wie ich das sehe, wird es, glaube ich, relativ problemlos klappen,
Also ähm die Mitglieder des Kernteams, sage ich mal ähm und diejenigen, die das jetzt schon auch sehr lange begleiten,
Denke ich mal, werden alle damit einsteigen? Ich auf jeden Fall und ähm ich denke, das sollte klappen.
Was ist deine Erwartung, wann das dann stattfinden wird? Weil man diesen Moment der Gründung erwarten ja nun alle schon seit längerem. Ist ja äh kein neues Thema.
Hm, also wir müssen, wenn wir dann wissen, ähm dass wir genug Gründungsmitglieder zusammen haben, natürlich eine Gründungsversammlung einberufen und ich denke mal, dass es im Sommer passieren wird.
Sommer zwanzig dreizehn, also.
Genau, also in wenigen Monaten.
Der beginnt ja in drei Tagen, ja, offiziell, also.
Also wir wollen das jetzt, ne,
so schnell wie möglich hinter ähm also was heißt hinter uns bringen, sondern über die Bühne bringen, dass wir den Rahmen haben, um dann halt auch tatsächlich ähm mit dem Crowdfunding,
Mitglieder zu gewinnen für diese Verwertungsgesellschaft, damit wir vom Deutschen Patent und Markenamt eben eine Zulassung bekommen, unsere Tätigkeit aufzunehmen,
Dafür brauchen wir natürlich Mitglieder, ähm es muss ja sozusagen auch in einer gewissen, also es muss eine gewisse Relevanz haben, damit das Patent im Markenamt sagt, ja gut, äh,
Wir sehen ein, dass es da äh tausende von Menschen gibt, die ihre Werke gerne von euch wahrnehmen lassen möchten. Also hier ist die Zulassung. So, das ist so der Traum.
Was ist jetzt so, ich meine, bisher hast du ja gesagt, du bist so explizit so für die Musiker der äh äh CC-Evangelist oder C3S-Evangelist. Was ist da jetzt so im Wesentlichen dein Pitch? Warum sollte man als Musiker Mitglied im C drei
Das schließt ja dann quasi auch eine Mitgliedschaft in der GEMA aus, oder?
Ja. Das ist äh durch die Art wie die Wahrnehmungsverträge bei der GEMA gestaltet sind, dadurch, dass du eben komplett alle deine Werke automatisch in den,
Wahrnehmungsvertrag mit einbringst, ähm ist das quasi nicht möglich, dass du auch noch Mitglied bei uns zum Beispiel in der Szene S wärst.
Also Mitglied könnte man ja werden, aber man könnte keine keine Werke dort einstellen und äh wahrnehmen.
Man könnte man könnte Genossenschaftsmitglied werden und Fördermitglied zum Beispiel, aber man könnte nicht seine Rechte wahrnehmen lassen durch die CDS, wenn man in der GEMA Mitglied ist.
Kommst da in die Falle. Wir hatten, das war, glaube ich, dieser Musik-Piratenfall bei dem in äh wir hatten da auch drüber berichtet, bei dem
Lieder oder Stücke unter Pseudonym veröffentlicht wurden, die GEMA hinging und sagte, ja Moment mal, wenn das unter Pseudonym ist, können wir ja nicht ausschließen, dass das eines unserer Mitglieder ist, also möchten wir dafür
Geh mal Beitrag haben. Und da die GEMA also als GEMA-Mitglied bist du quasi mit deinem mit deinem Namen,
Aber auch als also als Person selber. Und dadurch auch mit allen äh mit allen Werken, die du veröffentlichst.
Egal welchem Pseudonym. Das heißt, du könntest nicht sagen, äh ich bin jetzt hier äh äh warte mal, äh was wäre jetzt mein schöner Name? Wie, wie hast, du hast eine wie heißt nochmal, dein, dein aktueller Name, unter dem du veröffentlichst?
Rassel Jamira, du könntest nicht sagen, ich bin bei der C drei S und Rassel Jamiro bei der GEMA,
weil die GEMA dich als Danny Bruder hätte und Danny Bruder, egal was Danny Bruder macht, ist jetzt hier GEMA.
Pflicht.
Ja nicht so eine.
An
Genau, bei dem du müsstest das anmelden.
Soweit ich weiß, kann man nur eins anmelden.
Das ist einfach nicht Zukunftskompatibel.
Und daher schließt sich der schließt sich ja sowieso, schließen sich GEMA und die CC-Lizenzen aus und wenn ich einen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe und ich bin Mitglied der C drei S, kann ich dann mit einem meiner Pseudonyme sein,
Und dann auch gleichzeitig nur für die äh äh Creative Comments lizensierten Stücke, oder? Oder äh kann, würdet ihr.
Kannst als Mitglied der CDS kannst du selbst entscheiden,
Welche Werke du wahrgenommen haben möchtest durch die CDS. Du musst, ja genau, du musst überhaupt nichts einbringen,
Ähm von dem Album, was du jetzt gerade produzierst, sondern vielleicht nur von dem, was du vorher gemacht hast oder für das für das nächste oder du kannst irgendwie von Song zu Song entscheiden, den möchte ich irgendwie,
Unter dir und die Lizenz stehen und die wiederum und die unter die andere. Es muss auch noch nicht mal Creative Commons sein, es können auch andere freie Lizenzen sein.
Man macht das dann auch per Webformular oder so, also per AP. Kann man dann sozusagen seine Stücke da einfach submitten und dann kriegt man da eine Nummer dafür und dann ist das irgendwie klar.
Wie das äh, ne, also das ganze technische Backend oder Frontend. Wie sieht das alles immer so schnell? Das müssen wir natürlich.
Das ist noch nicht das steht noch nicht fest, aber so stelle ich mir das natürlich vor, ne.
Also wir wollen das äh einfach auf die Höhe der Zeit bringen auch, ne. Also.
Genau, ich meine, es wäre ja auch so, sagen wir mal so für Podcaster eigentlich äh optimal, dass man im Prinzip seine Besendung äh veröffentlicht und dann eben die Meldungen oder was auch immer, dann quasi erforderlich äh sein sollte, sei es jetzt,
Vielleicht in der theoretischen Zukunft,
eben auch für die Wahrnehmung der eigenen äh Rechte an diesem Podcast, aber eben dann auch gerade, was jetzt die Nutzung von Musik zunächst einmal betrifft, dass auch das eben dann darüber klar geregelt ist, dass man das eben direkt auf technischer Ebene automatisiert
man da eben auch gar keine große Arbeit mehr mit hat. Das kennt man irgendwie ein paar QR-Codes und das war's und äh gib ihm, ja.
Genau, also das ist äh unser Ansatz, dass wir so viel wie möglich automatisieren und eben durch die technologischen Möglichkeiten, die man heute hat, das Ganze wirklich so schmal wie möglich halten, was den also den den Aufwand an Verwaltung und äh
so angeht. Ne, weil es gibt einfach viele, viele Möglichkeiten, die äh einfach noch nicht genutzt werden,
eben auch durch die Tatsache, dass es eben nur eine Verwertungsgesellschaft gibt im Moment und da auch keinen Bedarf besteht.
Genau. Nochmal eine andere Frage. Hast du noch was Ninus?
Glaubte wir müssen zweiten Schritt kurz nennen äh also erster Schritt Genossenschaft gründen,
zweiter Schritt und dafür braucht ihr diese Absichtserklärung, für die ihr gerade auf der Webseite äh werbt, ne, dass ihr dann
wenn ihr die Genossenschaft habt, wollt ihr dann Verwertergesellschaft werden und dafür braucht ihr die um überhaupt zu sagen, hey, wir sind hier Verwertergesellschaft, braucht ihr genug Leute, die äh die sagen, ja wir wollen da uns auch von dieser Verwertungsgesellschaft
vertreten lassen und dafür habt ihr diese Absichtserklärung und davon braucht ihr möglichst viele jetzt.
Ja, also es ist schön, wenn so viele ähm aktive Musiker wie möglich die unterschreiben, damit wir einfach auch nachweisen können, dass es wirklich ein Interesse gibt an uns oder an der Existenz einer weiteren Verwertungsgesellschaft.
Keine formelle rechtliche Mitgliedschaft in irgendetwas mit verbunden, sondern da reicht einfach nur zu sagen ja für ich geil wie ich dabei sein hier Friedrich Wilhelm zack.
Genau, also das ist nicht verbindlich. Man kann auch hinterher sagen, ach, da an dem Tag war ich irgendwie komisch drauf, ich will das doch nicht, ne?
Man muss man wird nicht Mitglied, man muss auch nicht Mitglied werden, wenn man diese ähm Erklärung unterschreibt, sondern es ist einfach nur eine Sympathiebekundung, beziehungsweise eine Absichtserklärung, die halt sagt, ich würde da gerne Mitglied werden, wenn's die gäbe.
Das wäre das sozusagen, wenn wir jetzt mal hier von unserer Teilöffentlichkeit äh mal ausgehen, das ist sozusagen das, worüber man sich jetzt vielleicht als
Musikschaffender, der hier zuhört, potenziell erstmal Gedanken machen sollte, es geht jetzt nicht so sehr dadrum,
in dem ersten Schritt mit dabei zu sein, weil da seid ihr schon relativ entspannt, sondern es geht jetzt primär um diese Absichtserklärung. Welche Zahlen sind da jetzt erforderlich? Also wie viele Absichtserklärungen äh hättet ihr da gerne oder braucht ihr auf jeden Fall oder meint ihr vielleicht zu brauchen?
Ja, da gibt's keine wirkliche Zahl. Es gibt so viele wie möglich, wäre schön, ne, weil je mehr wir davon irgendwie auf den Tisch legen können beim äh.
Wie viele habt ihr schon? Könnt ihr das sagen?
Wir haben schon eine beeindruckende Menge an.
Die mal quantifizieren irgendwie, also.
Ich ich weiß es tatsächlich aktuell gar nicht. Ähm wir gehen, glaube ich, so auf.
Was ist wenn was für für euch beeindruckend ist, wissen wir ja nicht, ne? Vielleicht freut ihr euch schon. Ey, wir haben schon.
Uns beeindruckt schon die Eier, das hat mich schon beeindruckt. Ey, es gibt tatsächlich jemanden, der Mitglied werden möchte. Nee, ich glaube wirklich, ich glaube, wir gehen so auf die tausend Stück zu,
Und ähm es wäre schön, wenn das so weitergeht, dass wir einfach, ne, weil das je mehr wir davon haben, desto besser ist es, weil wir damit.
Denkst du denn, könnte das wir schätzen das Potenzial, also wie viele Künstler gibt's denn überhaupt, die Nichtmitglied in der GEMA sind?
Oh, ich glaube, es gibt ähm,
Man müsste jetzt natürlich ähm definieren, was ist jetzt genau heißt, Künstler, aber ich glaube, es gibt zigtausende davon, die nicht Mitglied in der GEMA sind,
Und ähm es gibt ja auch äh Bereiche, in denen es nicht wirklich sinnvoll ist, also ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt als DJ Mitglied Energie mal sein muss.
Mittlerweile ähm glaube nicht, nee.
Mittlerweile ähm mittlerweile hat sich das geändert, dadurch äh dass natürlich viele DJs einfach auch äh ja, selbst zu Musikern geworden sind.
Klar, das ist ein fließender Übergang. Die werden wahrscheinlich auch nicht äh ewig im Club stehen wollen.
Ja und ähm also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es mindestens nochmal so viele gibt, wie jetzt schon in der Gamer Mitglied sind, die nicht Mitglied sind. Also wahrscheinlich sind's mehr.
Hm. So und das heißt, wenn diese Absichtserklärung dann in möglichst großer Zahl zusammenkommen, also ihr seht da sozusagen, es gibt jetzt keine rechtliche,
Grenze ist nicht so wie bei einer Petition, wenn jetzt dreißigtausend zusammenkommen, dann ist die Sache klar, sondern es geht einfach nur dadrum eurem eigentlichen Antrag Gewicht zu,
verleihen, um die eigentlichen äh Bemessungs,
die da äh rechtlich vorliegen zu erfüllen, dass man jederzeit sagen kann, so das ist jetzt hier nicht so ein Spaß Projekt
und wir machen jetzt hier mal so die Anti-GEMA, weil wir grad mal Bock haben, diese GEMA-Vermutung fallen zu lassen und danach äh sammeln wir die Cola ein und bauen in der Nase und machen uns einen schönen Lenz. Sagen, äh es geht darum, einfach möglichst seriös aufzutreten und zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt diese europäische Genossenschaft als
Körper äh betreiben als, was in der offizielle
Name für diese Rechtsform, die ihr dann anstrebt, Verwertungsgesellschaft beschreibt's das schon.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, wie es dann am Ende heißen wird. Das habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken drum, weil ich weiß auch nicht, ob's da schon.
Nee, wer weiß, was was sozusagen der Rechtskörper ist, den ihr da beantragt? Was steht denn bei dieser Absichtserklärung drin? Wo ist denn das? Auf C3 S.
Punkt CC.
Natürlich, gleich schön,
International. Ähm absichtserklärung, genau. Hier geht's zum PDF,
Das geht derzeit an den Open Music Contest Punkt org.
Per Post. Ist aber jetzt sozusagen nur eine eine Hilfskonstruktion, also nur.
Da oben im Music Contest ist im Moment der ähm dass die Genossenschaft als rechts vor mir noch nicht gibt, sozusagen der äh.
Okay, also Verwertungsgesellschaft heißt es hier in der äh Absichtserklärung. Mhm. Das wollt ihr also werden.
Das ist klar. Ich habe jetzt gedacht, du meinst so, ob wir uns dann genau nennen.
Nein, nein, nein, der, der, die Rechtsform, weil,
klarstellen. Also es geht sozusagen nur nur dieser ganzen Diskussion im C3S, das merkst du auch schon an meinen Fragen, gibt's einfach viel Verwirrung so, ne? Und ich wollte das einfach mal äh äh auf äh spalten, also,
Kurz nochmal zusammengefasst, deshalb gibt es nichts. Demnächst,
eine europäische Genossenschaft gegründet werden. Eine Rechtsform, die es erst seit zweitausendsechs so gibt und das soll dann quasi so als äh Rechtskörper erstmal die die die organisatorische Grundlage sein, was bei der GEMA ein deutscher Verein ist. Ist
dann hier bei euch europäische Genossenschaft
Dann allerdings wollt ihr euch denselben Status erarbeiten, der da heißt Verwertungsgesellschaft, also Anerkennung als Verwertungsgesellschaft in Deutschland erstmal
nur oder.
Wir brauchen ja, da wir ja hier ansässig sind, äh diejenigen, die das jetzt gerade gründen, beziehungsweise bei einer europäischen Genossenschaft müssen's ja mindestens aus zwei europäischen Ländern Gründungsmitglieder,
sein. Und ähm wir brauchen für unsere Tätigkeit hier natürlich die Zulassung und die vergibt, ne, die gesetzliche Aufsicht hat die äh hat das deutsche Patent und Magen.
Genau, aber jetzt um die ganzen europäischen Dimensionen noch sozusagen äh äh näher zu kommen. Im Prinzip,
wäre es dann aber auch denkbar, dass man diese äh Anerkennung als Verwertungsgesellschaft auch in anderen europäischen Juristikionen sucht, wie es auch immer da äh im Einzelnen heißen mag, was weiß ich, in Frankreich,
Was ist da die äh die GEMA-Variante.
Oh Gott, wie heißen die.
Keine Ahnung. Also es gibt,
in all diesen Ländern gibt's halt äh äh etwas GEMA-ähnliches und im Prinzip in dem Moment, wo es dann Leute gibt, die sagen würden, ah, das ist ja eine prima Idee da mit der C3S, sowas hätten wir auch gerne. Wir würden auch gerne in unserem Land äh dieselbe Tätigkeit auf
Basis derselben Prinzipien durchführen, dann könnte dieselbe europäische äh Genossenschaft, also der selbe Rechtskörper auch,
die Anerkennung in dem anderen Land machen. Das heißt, man würde aus demselben Mitgliederstamm heraus äh Schritt für Schritt,
Die Europäisierung vorantreiben, indem man in immer mehr Ländern ähnlich arbeitet, ohne dass man jetzt immer wieder neue Mitglieder äh,
müsste oder neue Genossenschaften gründen müsste. Gut, dann habe ich's jetzt auch verstanden.
Und was denkst du, wie lange das noch dauern wird, bis dieser äh Anerkennung als Verwertungsgesellschaft durch äh sein wird? Oder mit wie viel Widerstand rechnet ihr da?
Ähm also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass die sind da selbst, glaube ich, ein bisschen gespannt beim Patent- und Markenamt, was da jetzt auf sie zukommt, weil das ist natürlich auch nicht so.
Sie so noch nie, ja. Hm.
Genau und ähm ich äh bin da guter Dinge, dass es irgendwie relativ zeitnah passieren wird. Wir müssen jetzt halt gucken, dass wir ähm eben im Juli starten wir das Crowdfunding, dass wir möglichst viele Mitglieder,
Also dass äh möglichst viele Leute Anteile zeichnen an der Genossenschaft. Mhm. Und das startet wie gesagt so Mitte Juli,
Und ähm sobald wir dann genügend Mitglieder beisammen haben und ich,
bin guter Dinge, dass das relativ schnell gehen wird. Hoffe, dass sehr stark und äh dann gehen wir dann hin zum Patent und Markenamt,
Hoffentlich äh ja noch in,
in diesem Quartal vielleicht sogar, ich weiß es nicht, aber vielleicht wird's auch Herbst und dass wir dann in der Lage sein werden, da genügend äh Mitgliedern vorzuweisen und Absichtserklärungen auf den Tisch zu legen und dann.
Hättet ihr gerne.
Tausende.
Tausende. Das ist immer so unkonkret. Sag doch mal was.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, so.
Der Millionen.
Ja, das wäre natürlich der Hammer. Eine Million, das da kennt man schon mit aushalten.
Oh Gott, nee, aber mit so viel Musikern in Deutschland, das äh.
Ja, also so ein, zweitausend wäre schon.
Linus, haben wir noch Fragen? Du bist äh ausgeschaltet?
Erstmal nicht mehr, ich hatte mich gerade kurz gemutet, nö. Wir können viel Glück wünschen und hoffen, dass äh sich auch viele Hörer äh diese diese Absichtserklärung anschließen.
So wie den Musiker unter unseren Folgenden haben, so.
Was wäre denn, wenn einfach jemand so was ausfüllen würde ohne Musiker zu sein? Oder kann man das gar nicht ausführen ohne Musiker zu sein?
Muss man da irgendeinen Status haben?
Man man sollte Musiker sein. Ne, also man möchte unterstützendes Mitglied werden.
Moment, hier steht, ihr müsst Komponisten, also,
genderte in Klammern, Komponistin, Texterin, Musikerin, Musikproduzentin, Remixerin oder DJ sein und bereits mindestens drei eigene Tracks geschrieben oder andere gemixt haben,
Ja, im Ergebnis müsst ihr also wenigstens Miturheberin von drei verschiedenen Musikwerken sein. Wir freuen uns.
Genau, also sonst gibt's ja keine Rechte, die man wahrnehmen kann.
Ja gut, aber das ist jetzt schon eine Bedingung, ne? Man kann jetzt nicht hier einfach sagen, so oh ganz konkret geht's erstmal nur um Musik.
Erstmal geht's nur um Musik, aber wie gesagt, man kann auch ähm ein Unterstützungsmitglied werden. Man muss jetzt nicht äh Musiker sein, um das Projekt zu verwirklichen oder verwirklichen zu helfen.
Gut später dann. Später dann aber nicht mit dieser Absichtserklärung.
Nee, genau, in der Absichtserklärung sind tatsächlich nur äh aus dem Berufszweig äh Musik ähm als Komponist oder Autor eben oder in irgendeiner Form beteiligt an Rechten von Musikwerken.
Mhm. Gut. Also die Podcaster dürfen jetzt erstmal sitzen bleiben. Es sei denn, sie machen gerade Musik. Linus, hast du denn schon mal Musik gemacht? Bist du schon, hast du schon drei.
Für dich immer von mir weisen. Ich glaube, ich habe drei Tracks gemacht, ja. Aber das äh das wäre eine eine Schande für die C drei S, wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie.
Eine An.
Nein, nein, nein. Wir würden uns geehrt fühlen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein, das würde oft für mich einfach äh alten Staub auf äh aufwirbeln, der.
Damals in meiner Punkphase.
Wo jetzt schon gutes Gras gewachsen ist, da will man ja jetzt nicht äh unnötig äh.
Also wir könnten, wir könnten jetzt hier sofort einen Track gemeinsam komponieren.
Der Lokbodennetzpolitik Online, das überlassen wir lieber den Remixern, ja, die können sich hier gerne über unser äh Werk hermachen. Ich äh glaube, wir haben uns eine halbwegs brauchbare äh Veröffentlichungslizenz hier zugelegt bei diesem Podcast,
Weiß gerade gar nicht. Na ja. Gut, dann machen wir jetzt mal Schluss.
Soll ich darf ich noch eine kezerische Frage stellen? An dich nicht. Woher kommt das Geld, was ihr sammeln wollt?
Also wenn ich ihr sagt, ihr seid jetzt eine Verwertungsgesellschaft. Ähm ich bin Mitglied und ich erwarte von euch, wie von der GEMA, dass ihr mir monatlich Geld überweist. Woher kommt das Geld?
Von iTunes.
Ach so, zum Beispiel, ach so, ah.
Na, das kommt überall daher, wo ähm Gelder ausgeschüttet werden für die Nutzung von Musik. Ist klar, also jegliches Portal, was äh was ich Spotify oder wie sie alle heißen, ne, was äh Musik.
Ah, das,
Das heißt, ich wäre ich würde dann eben nicht eine CC, also strategisch günstig wäre dann eben nicht die CC-Beilizens, sondern so eine CC äh bei NC, SA und schon kann ich auch äh sagen, okay, für eine
für eine Nutzung auf iTunes oder bei Spotify soll dann eben dieser Cent-Betrag an die C3S überwiesen werden. Okay.
Günstig, du kannst natürlich jede jede Lizenz wählen und das wird für jeden anders sein wahrscheinlich, aber,
Klar, also du kannst dann die Gelder kommen von überall da, wo sie jetzt auch schon herkommen, nämlich überall, wo Musik äh lizensiert wird oder genutzt wird oder öffentlich aufgeführt wird oder vervielfältigt wird,
Also es gibt eine interessante Sache mit der Lehrmedienabgabe zum Beispiel ähm ne, da wird sich zeigen, äh weil bei einer Creative-Community Lizenz, die mir die Nutzung und Weiterverbreitung erlaubt,
sicher, brauch ich ja auch nicht auch zusätzlich noch auf Lehrmedienabgabe zu zahlen, ne? Also das wird sich wahrscheinlich auch dann interessanterweise vielleicht einfach auch ein bisschen ändern in Zukunft. Mal gucken, wie das ist, weil der Gesetzgeber hat die ja eingeführt, um die Privatkopie,
irgendwie,
den Künstlern irgendwie auch zu verklickern, dass es wichtig ist und für die Gesellschaft und das muss ja möglich sein, dass man irgendwie in der Küche, im Bad und im Auto sich die CD an reinpacken kann, also kann ich die auch koch kopieren und dafür,
Gibt's halt die Lehrmedienabgabe und bei uns ist dann natürlich die Frage, müssen wir das Geld nehmen? Oder nicht? Also das wird sich,
Es wird sehr interessant sein darüber zu spekulieren, wie das dann in Zukunft zum Beispiel ablaufen.
Leute, die jetzt sich äh mit Absichtserklärung als potentielles Mitglied äh andienen und die dann ja dann im Idealfall auch äh Mitglied werden, sind dann aber voll Stimmenberechtigt. Das heißt, dieser eigentliche, diese eigentliche Ausbildung von, wie ihr es dann macht, ist dann letzten Endes quasi
Eine Frage dieser dort neu entstandenen Gemeinschaft. Das ist dann quasi der demokratische Prozess, den ihr dann auch umsetzen wollt. Und ich vermute.
Ja, ne? Jedes Mitglied hat äh eine Stimme und ist gleichberechtigt beteiligt an der Genossenschaft und an deren Geschäftsgebaren.
Wie wird das dann so ablaufen? Das heißt also wie bei dem bei den Piraten dann so, mit solchen Hallen, die sich dann füllen und dann schreit ihr euch dann an.
Genau, ja. Ja. Das ist auf jeden Fall klar, ne, sehr gesetzlich so vorgeschrieben, es müssen Mitgliederversammlungen abgehalten werden und wenn Entscheidungen,
Getroffen werden müssen. Alle Mitglieder daran beteiligt sein und ihre Stimme abgeben dürfen und sich.
Mhm. Und wollte dann auch äh so was wie äh einführen. Das war so was schon diskutiert worden so.
Wie gesagt, wir wollen, äh, wenn möglich, also, oder wie, soweit es in unseren Möglichkeit, äh, ist oder uns möglich ist, äh, das so abzudate wie möglich gestalten, ne, also, was uns rechtlich möglich ist, werden.
Das ist jetzt aber eine sehr, sehr politische Antwort, also ich meine, gibt's da schon konkrete Diskussionen in diese Richtung? Weil ich meine, das wäre ja, ihr habt ja dann erstmal dasselbe Problem, wie alle anderen Organisationen auch. Ihr müsst euch entweder so ein Delegiertenmodell,
schaffen, weil ihr wollt ja nicht angenommen ihr habt jetzt dreißigtausend Mitglieder, äh wollt ihr dann jedes Mal komplett Turnhallen äh füllen und sind nur die Leute da, die da sind oder äh ist eher über so eine,
ständige Mitgliederversammlung äh diskutiert worden.
Es äh wird sicherlich darüber diskutiert. Ich habe mich allerdings nicht daran beteiligt. Bis dato, weil ich äh ja, ich habe gerade andere Sachen zu tun gehabt wahrscheinlich. Ähm das kann ich dir nicht beantworten. Das weiß ich nicht.
Na gut, dann fragen wir da nochmal andere kritisch nach. Würde mich nämlich wirklich mal sehr interessieren, wie man jetzt so einen Körper da äh an Land kriegt und vor allem diesen diesen Konsens äh erzielen will, der hier erforderlich ist.
Ja, ich bin ich bin halt auch echt überhaupt nicht so rechtlich bewandert, wie das alles irgendwie ablaufen muss, was da erlaubt ist und was nicht und so. Das ist halt absolut nicht meine Abteilung so.
Und ähm ja, ich versuche mich immer.
Das sage ich auch.
So so gut informiert wie möglich zu halten, äh was natürlich teilweise etwas schwierig ist, so mit meinem Lebenswandel nicht immer so einfach zu vereinbaren,
einfach sehr viel Zeit dafür aufgewendet werden muss und die habe ich manchmal einfach auch nicht.
Deswegen ähm beschränke ich mich eigentlich auf meine Aufgabe, anderen Musikern davon zu erzählen, wie toll das ist,
kann jetzt aber nicht wirklich genau sagen, wie dann so eine Mitgliederversammlung abläuft. Äh,
Ich stelle mir das noch ganz traditionell vor, dass äh man dann zusammenkommt, aber wenn das rechtlich machbar ist, dass man irgendwie auch per also online eine Abstimmung mitmacht oder,
ja
Wäre mal spannend. Na gut.
Dann werden wir das sicherlich machen.
Dich nicht weiter mit solchen Detailfragen, die nicht in deinen Bereich fallen.
Genau, jetzt jetzt wird das hier noch so eine Anti-Werbung.
Ja, ja, nee, nö, ich meine, ist kann nicht jeder äh sich überall auskennen. Nina, das hast du noch äh Fragen? Hi. Gut.
Super, ja, wenn ihr euch informieren wollt, äh nochmal an alle, die das hören, ähm ne.
Punkt CC, allerdings bei uns in den Shownotes.
Genau und äh im Juli geht's los mit dem Crowdfunding und äh wir brauchen ganz viel Unterstützung auch äh ne, alle die Code schreiben können. Wir sind immer noch mittendrin, das Ganze zu programmieren und
Wir brauchen ganz viel Tipps, Tricks, Unterstützung und.
Und toller. Okay, super. Vielen Dank, Bruder, fürs Kommen.
Ja, danke euch.
Ansonsten, was äh steht sonst noch äh so an? Ja.
Proben.
Termine, Ankündigungen, ich bin äh diese Woche noch zweimal zu sehen, sollte ich vielleicht mal kurz äh erwähnen. Genau, ich bin in in Witten-Herdecke, da gibt's irgendwie so am Freitag, den einundzwanzigsten, den ganzen Tag so eine Podcast äh Veranstaltung, wer in der Region ist und äh
noch Zeit hat sich äh schön so einen Freitag äh lange in der Nase zu bohren, ist da herzlich äh willkommen
und am Samstag bin ich nochmal auf so einem Podcast-Event, das tummelt sich irgendwie gerade, man hat das Gefühl, es bewegt sich was. Äh und zwar hier in Berlin,
auch Link in die das findet statt in der Lipperstraße diesem ehemaligen Rundfunkgebäude.
Super Teil.
DDR genau, äh welchem Raum das jetzt konkret ist, weiß ich gerade gar nicht, aber ich glaube, wir gehen nicht in den tollen Konzertsaal. Äh,
da ist Teilnahme wie auch in dem anderen Fall kostenlos und wer Interesse hat, sich da an der äh Weiterentwicklung der Podcastlandschaft
beziehungsweise Weiterentwicklung dieses gesamten Radiogedankens äh da zu beteiligen, ist da herzlich eingeladen dazuzustoßen.
Link in den Shownotes.
Links links war ich noch, aber ich habe notiert, dass es rein muss.
Und du warst jetzt, glaube ich, erstmal genug an Aktivität.
Ich äh versuche jetzt mal irgendwie eine etwas ruhigere Woche zu machen, weil doch schon etwas anstrengendes Wochenende.
Okay, das war's. Tschüss. Und bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Ja, macht's gut. Tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.